all right welcome to new video and this
is some let's keep it sing again with ya
Hikaru Nakamura he's some playing a
couple of blitz games after his game
today em in Bilan vs. Magnus Carlsen and
this game which actually intended to
feature on video was rather a rather dry
affair with not much happening at all
so I decided to cover have a bit of
blitz action here the other another game
was drawn which would which also wasn't
too thrilling into one game is some
still running I'm glad resign yeah he
carry one against him grandmaster pencil
I are from Georgia so he again @g 66
opening of course he realized to blaze
unusual stuff both nights on the road
yeah this is very much in the style of
Duncan Suttles I mentioned him over Liam
the Canadian Grand Master of 70s who was
quite successful with those non
theoretical openings 27 however looks
like m'lip thinking more like we need 7
was intended so here blackest just
losing the deep one looks looks quite
grim for black this pieces are very very
passive also not sure how I can get the
pawn back yeah maybe this way but the
night only six would be in some sort of
pin also ok so he prepares 96 this is a
three minute blitz by the way so it
might get very faster near the end so I
can barely keep up with them any
comentary
yeah he got these six back and the worst
is over
the shoot-down should be okay now yeah
the knight on d4 is quite nice
yeah like should be okay now before
night is very very nicely placed and
like my try to uses three two two on the
Queen side it's got three pounds against
to enter this might be a nice trick here
neither three yeah he rarely misses
those those little things yeah I can
just take d4 and Bishop III could take
on c3 even Rock THC to and promotes yeah
amazing he calculated so quickly
young black still on two minutes 17 it's
likely to ya decide this game also on
time and white sari night only for my
black should be am technically winning
no be should be for coming maybe I can
just take here it's an extra bone and
two bishops white black has got the age
phone and he can also get another free
porn on the queenside yeah no you can
yeah I can even take it it's just the
simplest with g5 these pawns just yeah
March all the way through
[Music]
why lose I just spent one minute on this
game okay so let's see what kind of with
opening we got no other Tchaikovsky for
knock asunder this is really almost
conservative
yeah and c5 is a very straightforward
reply which leads to some technical mess
I would say Queen Jang a5 maybe about
you can play Queen d2 right Queen takes
Knight eggs it's okay
[Music]
you know looks like a pretty attractive
position for white now after blank
allowed e5 don't think I would have done
that or they can play out d6 to prevent
d5 this looks a bit a bit uncomfortable
only way to develop now the the is b5
and this might allow a form opening up
the Queen side you know we played a for
now maybe yeah this one was before White
is very nicely developed here Queen B
sick Knight b6 maybe now attacking me
for and c4 yeah very cheeky would be
Knight b6 Bishop d3 Knight a form in
grabbing the porn wow this looks very
risky inversion of the knight to f6 yeah
just take t5 now it takes the bishop of
Knight b6 looks terrible maybe maybe
it's not so bad
yeah black looks terrible but maybe
white cannot break through immediately
sometimes looks can be deceptive and
white also needs to take care of the f6
porn yeah I think but now black is okay
maybe 97 to come with attacking f6
yeah black should be okay really it's
got a good King on c6 and shakes this
week if it doesn't gets into trouble at
the time those two central pawns should
be very good now difficult to cover b3
yeah well you can cover it this way but
it doesn't look very active you have
like Lenny better now with the two
points maybe he'll get you get something
in this game then you better get on the
scoreboard it might be a whitewash
against taka I'm sorry
oh now the H pawn get some gets to play
its role so how does black make progress
now it's not so easy maybe mmm now why
does got the H porn
maybe he's finding really a way to spoil
this well know why it's better check
again now what is maybe man maybe it's
not better I thought you would get the a
pond like has some checks also you can
just take him before it's over yeah
before the a porn promotes yeah you just
took quick yeah he's still happy designs
yeah black spot a very good position
there
okay another night h6 well don't don't
don't try this at home with this kind of
stuff is certainly and not losing or
something but yeah it's quite risky you
should know what kind of riskier you're
taking but now I think maybe black has
some a good position here with with his
Knights it's not like not like an
advantage but tell the Knights do a good
job here in the center and he captured
with a knight on d6 so this piece is
really a quite active yeah
now the question is what about this pawn
duo in the middle f5 and e5 is it a
weakness or an asset for black can be
both on white white is scared I guess
wants to get rid of the Queen's but I'm
not sure that this is a good idea now
the king is very nice on f6 hmm I don't
know if I like this transformation for
black now what I would this is weird I
thought not 83 and then 94 also I think
this was much better and then white is
also better in this position now it
should be okay again from black I mean
it's just what I'm thinking it's those
guys have better blitz players than I am
maybe I'm wrong but I thought Knight h3
first would be better yeah okay what
what do we have now black advancing his
pawns on the Queen side he's got d5
blockaded with the night and he just
pushes whatever there is on the Queen
side he even gave up the h1 yams is
always playing for at most activity
now III also might be dangerous
yeah very difficult to assess this
pollution yeah I think I still like
lucky em but it's a very complicated of
course yeah he's in the pin now with the
c4 bishop
maybe the Sun can get white into trouble
and it's still not unpinning if you take
B 3 mm deep the e pawn is there some
trick with the e pawn I guess we'll see
soon Chuck this check I think white
overlooks the check I did as well and
now he to end the pawn promotes yeah he
just tricked him to death like three
times too many too many tricks
yeah who the black player here pencil is
very decent grandmasters rated like 2600
for for quite a while what you really
get thrashed here with all kinds of
weird openings
yeah here white um went for a quickie to
set up and we just won the e pawn I'm
not sure what black was doing there yeah
white is just a pawn up f3 and Bishop e3
and it's it's just a pawn
oh maybe we need another form okay so we
should merge five maybe you need to play
g4 oh what a way he needed to go Queen
d1 because of Knight g3 threatened and
after Queen e1 there was still two
pieces hanging so I think white wins
peace now he played this so quickly yeah
what is just a piece up with not much
else going on what is a little bit of a
beating king but yeah just Queen f3
Bishop d2 and so on maybe f5 now yeah
Bishop f4 g3 should consolidate yeah
nothing nothing much happen happening I
think black should throw in the towel
now ready
[Music]
yeah okay he continues but um I'm not
quite sure why this is very easy black
resigns yeah now you actually resigned
okay we got a new game I mean the new
opponent also titanium and this is a
three one blitz you just Varela down
yeah Carlos don't know this guy but
three thousand is not bad in blitz yeah
this is three one and it's a little bit
of a different game now with the
increment
yeah 9h sticks again intending Nagi for
I don't know but I think it's really a
bad idea to spend 40 seconds now naka
has been nothing and we'll just play a
normal move we should be 2 or f3 r h 3r
I'm not sure what he's doing you cannot
refute this so easily
yeah you just bring the knight to f7 and
build up this kind of fortress position
we had to add this before it's not
terribly grateful black but it's not
easy to to to tear down
[Music]
yeah what should be a better year with
age five any move basically it's just
that more space and black has a ton of
weaknesses d5 now maybe not sure what
happens after d5 or light be 3d five
something like this the only thing I
know is white will certainly wouldn't
want one on time this won't happen
[Music]
Wow long castles oh that's cool yeah
it's very really creative stuff here and
I guess why does a little bit
disappointed that black didn't cast a
shot after all yeah it's it's not quite
sure what what both sides should be
doing here white maybe play g5 at some
moment about how it took and this is
entirely different but you can go Bishop
c5 now maybe yeah now come where I only
spend 18 seconds up to now okay he got
increment but he's basically playing
this all instantly and white keeps
spending time yeah how does he have a to
now not at all
yeah 94 looks like disaster coming Queen
a - with Quincy for coming
maybe Mia Queen f7 that's a bit of an
irritating move here I'm not quite sure
what's happening Knight takes Queen f7 s
suddenly dangerous and got very unclear
position both sides stand badly I would
say yeah but look at the time now
somewhere I spent less time than the
other guys got left here Bishop f4 was
threatened
the problem here is did this H pawn on H
them if black loses this pawn and this
can easily happen then he will lose an
endgame but it's very tactical of course
but Bishop b2 coming maybe and stuff
like this
yeah instantly we should be for winning
in exchange not sure of it if it's
completely winning though yeah Black has
got rookie 7m okay so look f7 is no big
deal because of Ruby 7 so black should
be winning really
ya know before will will fall check
check yeah just kind of technique now so
and you will do it's got two minutes
extra I hope everyone made or almost
made Luke t8a form and it's over Chuck
[Music]
Jeff King is distracted so black will
win the the bishop also white forfeits
on time hmm I'm curious of the with the
white player really wants another game
oh he wants I'm not sure this can get
very ugly ah we've got nuts on the rim
so well well night h3 is rather usual
and in the dash to get the Knight to f4
at some point but Knight e3 years well
just a little bit of ridiculing your
opponent but you spend 20 seconds on the
reply ok 96 maybe wants to play e5
instantly it could be a good idea
yeah knight on h3 ok I understand on a
three it doesn't do much
yeah and black the black players just
too slow here
I mean it's increment that's all fine
but you have absolutely zero chance
against him if you're down to a couple
of seconds and naka has got two minutes
and while he's playing everything
instantly I don't know I don't know
what's what's the problem you know just
cancel or d6 or maybe maybe d5 it's also
not too crazy with a knight on a three
but you should really play it quicker
yeah maybe Knight see for getting this
piece and flavoured what can do all
kinds of things Bishop also Bishop g5
from F form tablet forth with strange
move B form also maybe okay one two - C
- maybe and ideas to play in d5 soon and
then follow up with 94
yeah this was a quick decision parting
with the important bishop but he wants
to grab the horn it seems [ __ ] leg should
have some compensation for the porn the
missing the missing bishop this is an
issue and I would like needs to open up
the position quickly now with d6 I would
say strangely enough the structure looks
looks a bit like like a scotch opening
as weird as it sounds
okay so black will get a pawn back with
t65 now yang once the play we should be
seven using the long diagonal again
maybe intending Queen III or Queen B -
yeah a black should be fine really
I don't think and now I can take on e
two also
yeah well this black shouldn't really
lose
I mean it's next report form yeah for
about nothing maybe some slight pressure
against the D pawn but it's still a dis
upon
like also has got this bishop possibly
on e4 which would be forward they would
consider now I'm just planting this
piece in the middle of the board
and you should be formed yg4 okay maybe
wants to prevent look on on d1 okay I'll
see that I'm like it's down to six
seconds I didn't really pay attention
you have like will lose on time or
blunder in time travel this is too low
six seconds I don't seem surviving this
shocked sorry
but black is is okay yeah is she's not a
matter of positional position is really
fine
maybe you manage even he's very speeded
up now yeah maybe it's about equal he's
got protected passes in the center check
maybe he's boulders I don't know what's
a pawn
okay yeah now what what what yeah yeah
it can take yeah we can take grab all
the points this is winning you're in
front of your pawn
if you're in front of your pawn and get
to the sixth rank you just win and
tonight manages exactly that
unbelievable that he actually wins
winning this all right black resigns
yeah just just a long time okay a new
opponent and the window somehow needs
adjustment so this is better yeah the
white player is some master from from
Russia from come Rukia also I can see at
the Hamill is called kumbhak and this is
Zhanna and sugar off is a very young
grunting Brent master I think I know
maybe 17 18 or something it's very young
and already above 2 to 6 you know
2,600 he beat Magnus Carlsen at Olympia
2010 in a nice game
ok so knock I went g5 here and then
sector porn it's followed by root g8
what can actually play Bishop age 5 now
but John have no idea what what this is
9 f 7 put 28 and it's a total mess I
know what this is really a total mess
but the knight on b7 if white takes b7
now VM should get his knight trapped and
what is this material was like as a
piece up right so he needs to take on b7
really I think hmm what he creates a
game Knight a5 is double check but it's
just the check I mean double check but
just king f7 or somewhere and I think
it's over yeah I think the night is just
lost I don't see how he how he saves it
[Music]
what does black have Dwight have it's
got two pawns yeah two points for the
mind but black is very active also the
screen on h5 is is quite a good piece
preventing long castles and it was short
you don't want to play as well
short Kasim very weakened oh I think
he's trying to reroute two cc's to c6
may also plugging up here holds on the
on the on the queenside where the king
is located quite a nice maneuver I think
now I can try do two legs somewhat we
had pawn structure and this King it's
got two pawns already and you can of
course continue to tried muddy the
waters here but maybe I took p6 now
threatening to take on d2 and on c4 if
white near one still needs to play c5 it
gets ugly
and black has got d5 first night don't
believe that anymore
yeah 95 should be great now yeah now
Knight X before every five just a5 and
white explodes here yeah black is
completely ready now White Rose I just
play king d7 or create and so on
so let's see what happens here this is
Queenie - again yeah black gown sort of
standard setup here with g6 and white
don't laugh a typical Kings Indian
attack II kind of position but here this
this is not a standard King side attack
but white playing in the center he's
gone through bishops also and black
tries to get some play against them the
white center pawns
yeah Queen a3 not sure what this piece
is doing really this might be might be
offside yeah white now threatens a 6 e 6
takes and Knight g5 stuff like this
[Music]
yeah maybe Bishop f4 now need to protect
e5 at some point and then some will be
Roxy 1e6 moves like that
yeah black young young is suffering a
bit from lack of space white simply has
more play here okay
tosses more wood into the fire black
cannot take on a one the exchange and I
think you should really get some
compensation for his troubles
yeah white will get some attack IAM
because well you have cut I will always
those Bishop h6 kind of moves and 95
then the bishop on g1 also comes to life
this is not at all easy to to defend for
black so yeah take a 95 threatening a
huge for Connelly 6 ok but black
multiply 94 or 95 94 but then Queen e7
interesting move Bishop h6 and I really
wants to get get to h6 and if black
takes now on f7 you've got Bishop h6 and
not g5 I think I think that's the idea
yeah of course black is severely down on
time yep like black needs to return the
exchange now yeah maybe with move like
this trying to get rid of the Queen's a1
also is hanging so what maybe needs to
take on e5 take on e5 take on f7 and
there's two bishops against two knights
with the P advantage but at least you're
not mated yeah this is of course a nice
and can now white with the two bishops
the apron is also the point to attack
yeah well blacks Knights of course
active it's not completely easy to
convert I think but white should be
clearly better
yeah maybe 92 coming like needs to
harass White's bishops trying to this
surprises me thought you would need to
really attack the bishops all the time
if White has got a little bit of time to
consolidate and get maybe a Bishop to b3
and so on then then he's just just very
much better
yeah he just played it yeah maybe just
trying to take it check a five and win
it simple chess and now Bishop to d2 and
try to take it yeah he managed to
finally win the a pawn and so has got
the two British bishops which are really
along be 2 and B 3 Rock c6 looks very
nice threatening all kinds of stuff okay
yeah well this is also 3 1 with 1 second
increment so like us down to just a
couple of seconds but he doesn't
necessarily need to lose on time the
position is completely lost though one
can just take on f5 no he ones and push
the a porn yeah ok decided to do it this
way should be winning a black Canary's
yeah this pawn promotes yeah close to
him taking the 2400 berry again and the
2001 with 3400 barrier again in blitz
yeah now in for a hippopotamus setup and
like actually with more time on the
clock and then up then at the beginning
of the game I don't know maybe preparing
98 possible
yeah the night went to g8 and well he
plays all his moves are instantly it's
just terrible time wise to to play again
that you're always down on time yeah
like it's just just doing nothing
besides playing very quickly
why should should have a nice position
but as usual in those kind of yeah head
shark hippo like positions it's not so
easy to break down you've got everything
covered
and why it doesn't have a very clear way
to to attack here but he can take t6 now
I think maybe you should you know take
t6 right somewhere then we very Bishop
g5 stuff like this yeah this is weird
why would you retreat the bishop don't
know okay maybe this wat the idea
getting a piece to c5 also yeah I
thought maybe a piece to c5 but he wants
to play h5
yeah I think this is a move that is
welcome public let this dangerous D free
Bishop is finally gone yeah now black
has a really great Bishop on b7 I don't
know it's hard for me to believe that
white should still have a dangerous the
tech now without without the d3 Bishop
if everything else fails black then I
can take you for play d5 close up the
position you know d520 then g5 maybe or
just taking you're taking us maybe even
better to get rid of this dangerous pawn
yeah don't see what what why he has here
like should be fine
it's got to also play against B to D for
now he tries to even get something on
the G phone not sure that this is
working but yeah h4 yeah now it's
definitely working yeah amazingly black
has drummed up something on the kingside
yeah maybe just grew up to six or
something I know what the Queen sorry
couldn't be five foot seven I just had
some hallucination there yeah like it's
just a pawn up and has a good position
Whitey's got weaknesses d3 d4 p2 or
black has everything nicely under
control yeah rook F 3 threat threatened
yeah - b8 yeah Black is just winning
he's also
to hunt more than two minutes left and
why does close to losing on time but as
mentioned its increment so it's not
totally hopeless
ya know g34 fellas wall Bishop III now
just to create white resigns yeah two
extra points the a a pawn and the H pawn
is really too much
and so another game how much is the
score at the moment it's just it's just
zero right yeah and let's let's check my
camera is on 100% still today he played
this funky beat the sponsor liar guy
also without a loss it was nine zero
against Ponce Alya and now it's two
versus I'd this Argentinian guy and this
is 14 in a row quite nicely yeah another
Queen to h4 kind of kind of crazy
opening that some may be around equal
this position not much happening really
yeah this is a about even I would say
the default is opened most likely we get
some exchanges there and it's a fairly
symmetrical kind of position yeah maybe
intending f5 something like this and why
trying to get something on the kingside
but it's um not much happening really
like it's fairly solid can just play a
normal use I think look t8 or something
like this yeah this also makes sense of
course trying to activate the b7 Bishop
yeah Ruka 4 would be nice but 96 wins
black cavity 6 this was a nasty threat
only six yeah this position is slightly
uncomfortable for like I think in a
practical blitz game you can easily slip
up in a way this was nice with you 5 but
Bishop Bishop can go to d5
I thought Bishop okay we should be
6-under should be three okay I see yeah
like black now I mean h4 is a weakness
and at the moment the rook is tied down
to this weakness yeah I think alike
should just get in some moves quickly he
can play g5 of course this is some yeah
no they got you got DD h pawn as a
passed pawn but wide also got rid of his
weakness on h4 so this is a bit
debatable if this really man means that
progress for black probably it does but
this rook on f4 is not doing much
position would be grateful black if the
rook world what would be on h8 or
somewhere else on the edge farm maybe
you can try to regroup this okay there's
a bishop bishop to h5 attacking at three
yards or so not a bad idea
yet sup cheb like I think he cannot play
for winner really and he's very much
down on time now it is doing a good job
maybe black is making some progress here
but he needs to be careful can always
blunder this with seconds on the clock
you should move at some point okay yeah
black managed to get the roof to age 6
and now Road the ape on the h-bond sorry
yeah maybe the soil pond promotes I
Bishop III was yeah okay I see now
Bishop a 3-2 to sector Bishop yeah now
black can needs to be a bit careful
again it is only got a second on the
clock should we draw them maybe not a
draw anymore
so yeah this must be winning now the
pawns are too far apart it should be
winning
so sure check check check check check
yeah it should be winning it should be
winning shot check zombie six and seven
probably push the pawn now and black is
good off yeah this is wins no really
check black resigns yeah I think I'll
stop at this point videos on fifty
minutes and I actually need to get some
some dinner here alright thanks for
watching out but I was entertaining it
was a real show here by Nakamura one all
it splits games in somewhat weird
fashion
opening wise alright thanks for watching
and hope you got entertained
she isn't by